Michael where's my weight from this  moment ah what is that oh you know an  Academy Award Oscar run it Oscar road  trip you're not going to touch this  amazing thing hi I have so many people  to thank just a moment I'd like to thank  my fifth grade school teacher who taught  me how to tap and tell me to believe in  myself I'd also like to thank central  groceries in New Orleans for for letting  me have a free mufa lata okay there same  I also would like to thank sandra  bullock's and and Betty White and the  man who played the football in the blind  side and of course i'd really like to  thank or worse pricing because i saw her  in funny girl and people love Oscars  will do are the luckiest people i love  you ask her